et je dois enlever j'écrivais partie il
y en a froid soleil un chamboule tout
pour retrouver les produits de la paella
cet après midi la formation de ces
futurs animateurs c'est grand jeu avec
ateliers stands
jean-luc travaillent déjà dans
l'animation mais il profite de ce stage
pour renforcer son bagage professionnel
il ya beaucoup plus de responsabilités
qu'on pense parce qu'il faut dire ce qui
est basse et les enfants c'est des
enfants de parents qu on donne encore
savoir créer encadrer un jeu travailler
en équipe
certains des stagiaires sont encore
mineurs ils apprennent donc aussi à se
responsabiliser et comprendre le public
accueilli ces trades ans parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de théorie avoir la
connaissance de l'enfant la sécurité la
réglementation comment s'organise une
journée sur un accueil de loisirs ont un
séjour de vacances mais aussi il faut
apprendre à tester des techniques et
puis à se créer sa petite trousse à
outils d'animateurs âgés de 17 à 26 ans
et stage es18 jours pour apprendre les
bases du métier
à l'issue de cette session si elle est
validée par l'équipe encadrante ces
jeunes pourront s'occuper d'enfants de 3
à 17 ans lors de leur stage pratique et
peut être sur magny les hameaux
le service jeunesse de la commune les
accompagnons dans leurs recherches